it wasn't that long ago that Keanu
Reeves made his first appearance as head
shot happy dog loving hitman John wick
in the critically acclaimed film of the
same name
in the years since though the world of
assassins and gold coins that he lives
in has grown considerably and will be
expanding a whole lot more in the near
future there's already a line of comic
books slowly revealing more about wick
shadowy past and a TV spin-off is
currently in the pipeline at stars both
are exciting projects but it's Rives
third outing as the steely antihero that
everyone's really waiting for from
returning characters and exotic filming
locations to production schedules and
release dates this is everything we know
about John wick chapter 3 the band's
back together the biggest obstacle for
John wick chapter 3 was always going to
be convincing Keanu Reeves to reprise
his role as he found out with the Matrix
trilogy third time isn't always a charm
luckily for wick fans Reeves was
expressing his interest in a third film
before the second one was even released
in February 2018 Reeves said that he was
absolutely on board for John wick
chapter 3 telling Entertainment Weekly
that he loves the character and the
world and that if audiences were into
what he did in the sequel he'd have the
chance to continue it turns out they did
chapter 2 racked up an 89% fresh rating
on Rotten Tomatoes and Reeves got his
wish with chapter 3 being set for
release in summer 2019 writer Derek
Kolstad came aboard in summer 2017 and
Chad still s key who co-directed and
directed John wick and chapter 2
respectively is back on board two
familiar faces with John wick success
it's no surprise that producers have
been spending a whole lot of time
figuring out how to continue the
characters story when chadster Leske was
asked for more details he revealed that
chapter 3 is going to bring a few
characters from the periphery of the
action into the spotlight Stahl s Key
has mentioned that Ian McShane and Lance
Reddick will both be back in prominent
roles meaning that the continental our
hotel the caters to working assassins
will likely play a key role in the film
wick was excommunicated from the hotel
for conducting business on its grounds
in Chapter two but judging from these
early comments it looks like he's not
done with the secretive underworld
establishment just yet Common Laurence
Fishburne and Ruby Rose are all
to reprise their roles as well the last
time we saw Rose's character the mute
assassin Aries she was bleeding out in a
Hall of Mirrors after making the mistake
of fighting John wick apparently it'll
take more than that to stop her on the
road while John wick was set entirely in
New York Chapter two took him to the
gloriously cinematic city of Rome and it
looks as though he'll be getting at
least one new stamp in his passport in
part three
according to Celestia's interview with
Digital Spy the plan is to keep weak on
the move and numerous destinations have
already been tossed around behind closed
doors
Dallas Key said we talked about the UK
Paris we'd love to do the Middle East
and Asia Reeves even told IGN that he'd
like to see John in Jerusalem sending
him into the desert in an effort to go
somewhere with a history that goes
beyond even Rome's
it ultimately falls to rider Derek
Kolstad to shape week's journey and his
choice is Tokyo who told the Jeff
Goldsmith podcast one of the things I
would love John to do in the third one
is to be excommunicated broke begging in
Tokyo or some corner of the earth that's
sexy and cool taking the story to Japan
might help to underline Wyck status as a
sort of modern-day ronan and recent
reports suggest that this might just be
what the producers are going for
Hiroyuki Sanada who formed a friendship
with Reeves on the set of the samurai
flop 47 Ronin has apparently joins the
cast as the central antagonist the boss
of a Japanese crime syndicate pull up a
chair to the high table while 2014's
John wick was a straight-up revenge
flick the 2017 sequel fleshed out the
mysterious world of professional killers
considerably revealing the existence of
an all-powerful Council of assassins and
crime lords known as the high table
kimonos double Santino's open contract
has gone international a table according
to Kolstad in one of the early script
drafts we went in depth on what the high
table is until we realized it was too
much for one story
luckily coal studs interview seemed to
indicate that chapter 3 will finally go
for it which was then confirmed by the
director Reeves also teased the high
tables involvement in chapter 3 during
an interview with Empire saying maybe
the high table shows up and then the
high table starts firing guns and then
maybe this kind of thing starts to
happen between the high table and
continental
wouldn't that be awesome John wick the
end as it stands John week chapter 3
will be the last movie that will focus
on Reeves character at least as far as
the filmmakers are concerned asked by
the independent if he saw the third
chapter as the final one Chad still s
keys answer was yes although he left the
final decision in the hands of Lionsgate
it seems like there's a slim chance
Reeves could return in a fourth film but
it's more likely that the studio is
planning on doing more John wick movies
without the character according to The
Hollywood Reporter Lionsgate has already
purchased a screenplay called ballerina
described as Luke Vasant meets Quentin
Tarantino
with the intention of releasing it as a
John wick spin-off there's been little
news of the project since which suggests
that Lionsgate intend to see the John
wick trilogy out before expanding the
universe that doesn't mean that Keanu
Reeves will never play the character
again though in January 2018
stars the television network owned by
Lionsgate confirmed that it was
developing a TV series called the
Continental while it's based on the
hotel that wick and the other assassins
frequent it's been revealed that Reeves
would not be the star but will still
reprise the role for occasional
appearances with chapter 2 introducing
an incredible number of new characters
and chapter 3 set to possibly involve a
conflict between the Continental and the
high table there's plenty to work with
in the wider John wick universe as long
as all the assassins know they should
stay away from everyone's pets thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
you
[Music]